En esta ocasión vamos a seguir trabajando
con sistemas de ecuaciones,
pero esta vez quiero ver sistemas de ecuaciones consistentes e inconsistentes,
es decir, los sistemas de ecuaciones que no tengan solución o en dado caso,
que tengan una infinidad de soluciones,
pero antes de eso, vamos a ver un sistema
mucho más sencillo y consistente,
así que veamos este sistema.
Tengo "3x" menos "4y" y esto lo voy a hacer
igual a 13 y por otra parte me voy a tomar
"y" igual a "-3x" menos "y"...
"-3x" menos "y"...
Y bueno, lo quiero resolver por el método
de suma y resta o de eliminación y por lo
tanto, para ello, lo que voy a hacer es copiar
la primera ecuación tal cual,
esa la voy a dejar tal cual
y la voy a poner de este lado.
"3x" menos "4y" esto es igual a 13 y por otra
parte, la segunda ecuación,
quiero que te des cuenta que no tiene los términos reducidos, por lo tanto, para reducir términos,
todo lo que tenga que ver con "y" de un lado de
la ecuación, lo que voy a hacer es restar
"y" de ambos lados de la ecuación y por lo
tanto vamos a restar "y" aquí,
esto me va a quedar 0,
del otro lado me va a quedar "-3x" menos "2y"
y bueno, ya tengo la otra ecuación
y fíjate que bueno, aquí tengo "-3x", mientras que acá arriba tengo "3x", esto me va a servir bastante
para usar el método de suma y resta,
pero bueno, vamos a copiar esta ecuación
aquí abajo, "-3x" menos "2y"
esto igual a 0...
Y apliquemos el método de suma y resta porque
ya nos dimos cuenta de que podemos eliminar
la "x" de una manera muy rápida, por lo tanto,
vamos a hacer el método de suma y resta
del lado izquierdo y del lado derecho.
¿Y del lado izquierdo qué me va a quedar?
Déjenme poner aquí una línea que es la
que me falta y entonces me queda,
"3x" menos "3x", estos dos se van,
se eliminan, se cancelan
y después me queda "-4y" menos "2y"
esto es "-6y"
y por otra parte tengo 13 más 0,
13 más 0 es 13.
Y bueno, ahora para despejar el valor de "y",
voy a dividir ambos lados de la ecuación
entre -6...
entre -6, entre -6...
y por lo tanto, me queda que el valor de "y"
es igual a 13/6 negativo o dicho de otra manera
-13/6, muy bien, este es el valor de "y"
de mi solución.
Y ahora necesito también sacar el valor de "x",
no lo olvides.
Y para eso, lo que voy a hacer es agarrar
la primera ecuación y voy a sustituir el
valor de "y" en la primera ecuación,
entonces me queda, "3x" menos "4y"
pero "y" vale -13/6, esto es igual a 13.
Y bueno, vamos a despejar a "x",
entonces menos por menos me da más
y aquí puedo sacar mitad, la mitad de 4 es 2 y la mitad de 6 es 3, esto es mucho más fácil de multiplicarlo,
entonces me queda "3x" más 2 por 13 es 26,
26/3, esto es igual a 13, sin embargo,
al 13 lo vamos a ver de una vez en tercios para
que se pueda simplificar fácilmente con este
26/3, 13 es lo mismo que 39/3...
39/3...
Y ahora si, voy a restar 26/3 de ambos lados
de la ecuación, para que de esta manera pueda
despejar mucho más rápido a "x", entonces
-26/3 de este lado y -26/3 de este otro.
¿Y entonces qué me va a quedar?
Del lado izquierdo pues solamente me queda
"3x" porque estos dos se cancelan,
mientras que del lado derecho,
39/3 menos 26/3 es lo mismo que 13/3.
Y ahora, voy a dividir todo entre 3 para que
ahora si obtenga el valor de "x",
voy a dividir todo entre 3 o multiplicado por 1/3, entonces mejor vamos a multiplicarlo por 1/3.
Multiplicando por 1/3, estos dos se van,
me queda que "x" es igual a 1/3 por 13/3,
esto es lo mismo que 13/9.
Muy bien, ya tengo el valor de "x", es decir,
que la solución de este sistema de ecuaciones,
es "x" igual a 13/9, "y" igual a -13/6 y por
lo tanto, estamos hablando de un sistema consistente,
porque tiene una única solución, este sistema
de ecuaciones es un sistema consistente,
porque el punto de intersección de estas
dos rectas es el punto 13/9, -13/6...
vamos a apuntarlo...
Sistema consistente...
consistente...
Muy bien.
Y ya que tengo que este es un sistema consistente,
pues, podremos imaginarnos un sistema que
no sea consistente, un sistema inconsistente,
¿y cómo se vería?
Entonces vamos a tomar otro ejemplo para ver
e ilustrar a qué me refiero.
Imagínense que yo me tomo la ecuación "5x"
menos "4y" igual a 1
y me voy a tomar otra ecuación,
la ecuación "-10x" más "8y"
y esto lo voy a hacer igual a -30.
Y bueno, yo quiero resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones y lo quiero resolver por el método
de eliminación o de suma y resta.
Y bueno, para esto tengo que elegir una de
las variables a la cual voy a eliminar.
Y voy a decir que quiero eliminar a la "x"
y por lo tanto voy a multiplicar la primera
ecuación por 2, de tal manera que me queda
"10x" menos "8y" esto es igual a 2,
2 por 1 = 2.
Y date cuenta que ya con esto eliminamos a
la "x" porque me queda "-10x" más "10x"
y entonces vamos a sumarlo de una vez.
Entonces sumemos esta parte de la ecuación
y me queda "0x"...
"0x" del otro lado tengo "0y" también y después
tengo que esto es igual a -30 más 2,
que es -28, pero "0x" más "0y" es lo mismo que
0 y entonces me queda la igualdad 0 igual a -28.
Y aquí hay algo raro,
¿te das cuenta?
¿Qué pasó aquí?
Porque al final,
¿cuándo 0 es igual a -28?
Pues nunca, nunca 0 es igual a -28 y cuando
nos pasan estas cosas bizarras,
esto quiere decir que no tenemos solución y éste es
un clásico ejemplo de un sistema inconsistente,
cuando llegamos a algo que es bastante absurdo,
0 igual a -28, algo que no tiene sentido,
estamos hablando de un par de ecuaciones o
un sistema de ecuaciones que no tiene solución.
Y cuando pasa esto, es uno de los ejemplos
de un sistema inconsistente,
cuando no tenemos solución,
¿y por qué pasó esto?
Suena muy raro lo que está pasando, ¿no?
Pues vamos a intentar graficar estas rectas
para que entiendas un poco mejor lo que está
pasando y porque no tenemos solución,
así que déjame agarrar la primera ecuación,
"5x" menos "4y" igual a 1 y vamos a ponerlo
en la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
para que la podamos graficar y para esto,
pues lo que hay que hacer es despejar a "y",
por lo tanto voy a restar "5x" de ambos lados
de la ecuación, de tal manera que me queda
"-4y" es igual a "-5x" más 1.
Y ahora voy a dividir todo entre -4,
para que ahora si me quede el valor de "y" despejado,
vamos a dividir todo entre -4...
todo entre -4
y por lo tanto, aquí me queda que
"y" es igual a -5/4 menos 1/4, perfecto.
Ya tengo la primera recta en la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen, pues vamos a hacer lo
mismo con la segunda ecuación, vamos a tomarnos
la segunda ecuación y vamos a despejar también
a la "y", para que así obtengamos una recta
de la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
y la podamos graficar.
Y bueno, lo que voy a hacer es despejar a
la "y" por lo tanto voy a pasar el "10x"
del otro lado con signo contrario y me queda "10x"
menos 30 y después dividiendo todo entre
8, me va a quedar...
¡Oh espera!
aquí hay algo raro...
me va a quedar 5/4 de "x" menos...
y 30 entre 8 es lo mismo que 15 entre 4,
menos 15/4,
lo único que estoy haciendo son
reduciendo las fracciones,
10 entre 8 son 5/4, 30 entre 8 son -5/4...
espera, por aquí debe haber algo mal,
por eso te decía que me sonaba que había algo raro...
es que aquí es más...
claro, claro claro...
menos entre menos me da más,
cuando yo divido todo entre -4,
me queda -5 entre -4, lo cual es positivo y después
1 entre -4, lo cual es -1/4, ¡perfecto!
Ya tengo aquí a mis dos rectas en su forma
pendiente ordenada al origen
y ahora vamos a graficarlas, pero lo primero que quiero
que te des cuenta antes de graficarlas
es que tenemos la misma pendiente,
tenemos dos rectas con la misma pendiente,
¿qué significa eso?
Bueno, seguramente ya tienes una idea o ya
recordaste que significa eso,
pero de todas maneras vamos a graficarlas para que te des cuenta de qué es lo que está pasando.
La primera corta en -1/4, es decir justo aquí
y como tenemos una pendiente de 5/4,
por cada 4 que avancemos, vamos a subir 5,
entonces pasamos por aquí y entonces también
para abajo y se forma una recta muy parecida a ésta, mientras que la otra recta,
¿cómo se va a ver?
Bueno, corta en -15/4, -15/4 es mucho más
abajo que -1/4, por lo tanto lo voy a poner
esto es como si divido 15 entre 4...
me da como...
3.75...
es -3.75, por lo tanto,
está mucho más abajo que el -1/4 y por lo tanto,
¿qué me queda?
Vamos a suponer que este es el -3.75,
el -15/4 y entonces voy a subir una pendiente de 5/4,
quiere decir lo mismo que por cada 4 que yo
avance a la derecha, entonces voy a subir 5,
por cada 4 yo voy a subir 5 y entonces
obtenemos una recta muy parecida a ésta.
Perfecto.
Ya tengo aquí a otra recta.
A la recta que es la representación gráfica
de mi segunda ecuación y lo que quiero que
te des cuenta, es que estas dos rectas son
paralelas, como tienen la misma pendiente,
son dos rectas paralelas, por lo tanto estas
rectas nunca se van a intersectar,
recuerda que dos rectas paralelas
nunca se intersectan.
Es decir, este sistema inconsistente,
no tenía solución, porque realmente estamos hablando
de 2 rectas que son paralelas, pero las rectas
paralelas nunca se intersectan, por lo tanto,
nunca vamos a encontrar
un punto de intersección entre ellas.
Esta recta sale de graficar esta ecuación
que tengo de blanco, mientras que esta otra
recta sale de graficar esta ecuación que
tengo de amarillo.
Y por lo tanto, como son rectas paralelas,
entonces no existe ningún punto en común,
no hay ningún punto en común y por lo tanto
no hay un punto de intersección.
Pero bueno, vamos a agarrarnos otro ejemplo
de estos sistemas raros que tenemos aquí.
"4x" más "5y" igual a 0 y "3x" es igual a
"6y" más 4.5 y bueno, de hecho...
no, espérame, espérame...
porque estas ecuaciones que tengo aquí
son muy parecidas a las ecuaciones que tengo en
el ejemplo anterior,
pero yo quiero ver todas las posibles opciones que tengamos de sistemas de ecuaciones
que no sean consistentes,
así que mejor déjame tomarme ésta.
"3x" menos "7y" esto va a ser igual a 1
y por otra parte me voy a tomar,
la ecuación... "6x"...
déjame ponerlo aquí...
"-6x" más "14y" esto es igual a -2.
Muy bien, ya tengo aquí un sistema de ecuaciones
y si yo lo quisiera resolver por suma y resta,
pues entonces lo que hay que hacer es primero,
recuerda, elegir una de las variables para eliminarla
y vamos a eliminar la "x",
por lo tanto, lo que me hace falta para eliminar la "x"
es convertir este "3x" en "6x" y para eso lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar la primera ecuación por 2.
Entonces déjame ponerlo de esta manera,
si yo lo quiero resolver por suma y resta,
entonces tengo que multiplicar esta ecuación por 2,
¿y qué voy a obtener?
Vamos a ponerlo mejor aquí abajo para que
quede todo mucho más claro,
voy a multiplicar por 2.
Bueno, si multiplico esta ecuación por 2,
obtengo "6x" menos "14y",
esto es igual a 2.
Y perfecto, ya podemos eliminar la "x" porque
en la ecuación de arriba tenemos "-6x",
en la ecuación de abajo tenemos "6x"
y por lo tanto vamos a sumarlo.
0 más... oh, oh... más 0, esto es igual
a... 0, es decir que 0 es igual a 0
y esto realmente no es una atrocidad,
porque 0 sí es 0.
Sin embargo, esto se le conoce como un sistema
dependiente,
cuando llegamos a soluciones del estilo, 0 igual a 0, estamos hablando de un sistema dependiente,
¿y qué quiere decir esto?
Bueno, qué te parece si tomamos cada una
de estas ecuaciones y las ponemos en su forma
pendiente ordenada al origen, para graficar
las rectas y ver y entender mejor
qué es lo que está pasando
con un sistema dependiente.
Ojo, si tenemos un punto de intersección,
es un sistema consistente,
si llegamos a algo medio bizarro
de la forma 0 igual a una constante,
estamos hablando de un sistema inconsistente,
pero si llegamos a algo de la forma 0 igual a 0,
estamos hablando de un sistema dependiente.
Entonces tomemos la primera ecuación y vamos
a despejar a "y" y me queda que
"-7y" es igual a "-3x",
ya lo pasé del otro lado más 1.
Y ahora voy a dividir todo entre -7 y me queda
que "y" es igual a menos entre menos me da más,
a 3/7 de "x" menos 1/7,
"y" es igual a 3/7 de "x" menos 1/7.
Ahora tomemos la segunda ecuación y la segunda
ecuación nos decía que
"-6x" más "14y" es igual a -2 y de igual manera,
vamos a despejar a "y",
y para esto, voy a pasar del otro lado
este "-6x"con signo positivo y lo que me va
a quedar es que "14y" es igual a "6x" menos 2
y dividiendo todo entre 14,
me queda que "y", es igual a 6 entre "14x"
menos 2 entre 14, sin embargo,
estas fracciones las puedo simplificar,
me queda que "y"
es lo mismo que 3/7 de "x", menos 1/7.
Y bueno, aquí está ya escrita mi segunda
ecuación en su forma pendiente ordenada al origen.
Ahora, lo que quiero que te des cuenta y lo
importante que tenemos que ver aquí,
es que si nosotros graficamos estas dos ecuaciones,
vamos a llegar a algo muy curioso,
porque si yo me tomo mi primer ecuación y la grafico,
primero date cuenta que tenemos
una ordenada al origen de -1/7,
así que tenemos una ecuación
por aquí y después si yo agarro la segunda
ecuación y la grafico, ¿qué crees?
Tenemos la misma pendiente y tenemos la misma
ordenada al origen, por lo tanto me estoy
refiriendo a la misma recta, la gráfica de
esta ecuación es la misma recta que la ecuación
del principio y por lo tanto tenemos muchos
puntos que coinciden, éste de aquí,
éste de aquí...
tenemos muchos puntos, tantos como una infinidad.
Es decir que un sistema dependiente,
lo que nos dice es que tenemos
una infinidad de soluciones
porque todos los puntos son soluciones,
todos los puntos de esta recta son solución,
porque son la misma recta.
Y de hecho por eso se llaman dependientes
y de hecho se llaman ecuaciones dependientes
porque podemos obtener una ecuación con la otra,
si te das cuenta podemos obtener la
segunda ecuación multiplicando la primera
por -2, para todas las "x" y todas las "y"
que estén en esta recta, se cumple para el
punto 1, 2/7 para el punto 0, -1/7...
esto es lo que se llama un sistema dependiente.
Y bueno ya aquí tenemos la tercera opción,
así que déjame hacerte un pequeño repaso
de todo lo que vimos en este video,
si nosotros tenemos dos rectas y las rectas se intersectan en un solo punto,
estamos hablando de un sistema
consistente y tenemos solamente una solución,
aquí están mis dos rectas y su punto de intersección,
si tenemos algo que es bastante
loco, como por ejemplo aquí, 0 igual a -28,
estamos hablando de un sistema inconsistente
y son dos rectas paralelas, por lo tanto no
tenemos solución, este era el segundo caso,
¿recuerdas?
Y el tercer caso es cuando nosotros tenemos
algo que es obviamente cierto, 0 igual a 0.
Y en este caso tenemos un sistema dependiente,
lo quiere decir que tenemos una infinidad
de soluciones porque estamos hablando de la
misma recta.
Así que espero que hayas encontrado todo
esto útil y nos vemos en el siguiente video.